[Música]
[Aplausos]
el vecinos que por alguna discapacidad
alguna enfermedad no pueden acarrear y
los mismos vecinos se ayudan entre ellos
para poder tener o solventar el día de
la falta de agua
[Música]
hay que recordar lo que lo que está
determinado en la ley de aguas
nacionales donde en épocas de crisis o
de incertidumbre siempre hay una
prioridad en el consumo humano sobre las
explotaciones industriales y agrícolas
sin embargo eso no está ocurriendo de
manera suficiente la realidad es en el
sentido contrario
luego se piensan en radicalización es de
que hay que cerrar empresas hay que
usted me parece que en este momento esa
etapa es impensable no es posible por lo
cotidiano de la vida digamos la vida
pública de la ciudad está articulada en
grados importantes con la actividad
industrial de comercial
[Música]
ah